thank you very much can you hear me or
yeah we still cannot hear you
can you hear me now
did you say yes
yes yes okay very good
okay
so
this
today i will use slides rather than hand
written stuff and
which means i will go less into
sort of details and proof
and more sort of an overview
however i will i will start with a
couple of minutes sort of round up from
last lecture so for that reason i will
start by going back to my handwritten
stuff so now i will try to
share screen with my
ipad let's hope that works
so can you see my handwritten stuff this
was uh
this whole thing was from last time
up until uh
so last the last thing i wrote
on tuesday was this
one thing i would like to add was that
all the results
i talked about
on tuesday none of them were my results
so
it was just the
results from others and quite a lot of
folklore and i wouldn't know who
was the first approving each of those
results
however
i have written
two research monographs or maybe even
three research monographs and you can
find the results with more details
in two of these books well actually in
the third one i wrote one a couple of
years ago as well but maybe the first
two are better so one was published over
20 years ago
with a swedish colleague and then uh
nine years ago with two dutch colleagues
uh order diekmann and hans estebeck
so if you want to learn more about
details in the proofs you can go to
those two books
i think i mean
unfortunately it was lagging
can you repeat the question
i just said we actually ordered one of
your books and it's upstairs for people
to look at
okay very good
so i'm i'm at my summer court which is
i'm at my summer cod
and i'm afraid that my connection is not
as good as last time so let me know
if i'm lagging or something
anyway
i didn't say all that much explicitly
about the final size for the
the standard epidemic model that i
talked about
can you turn
now i go to comedy can you turn your
ipad sideways yes sorry for that
there we go
uh
so uh
i will say a few more words about
this thing
the
probability of a minor outbreak
we call that thing pi
and
an expression
for
getting
[Music]
infected
in case of a major outbreak
uh
okay and hopefully you remember that the
initial so i would say a few words about
uh this pi the probability of a minor
outbreak and
an expression for the final fraction
getting infected in terms of the modal
parameters
the initial phase i hope you maybe
remember this
of the epidemic
was well approximated by a branching
process
and what about the offspring
distribution i didn't
say this explicitly
so you could sort of think of the model
if this is the index case maybe if you
remember you were infectious for a
period
and during this period you infected each
other individual at some rate beta over
um
beat over n and you did so for an
a random infectious period time
and uh
so
maybe it looks like this that the
here you have the index case you are
infectious for a random period of time
and maybe the outcome is that you infect
three people
and then
maybe you recover and then these three
people
they will have sort of the same uh
outcome so they will also infect
according
during the infectious period at the same
rate maybe this one didn't inflate
anyone this one affected two and this
one affected three
so what is the distribution of how many
people you infect
well
if you first
condition on the duration of the
infectious period
then
you infect
a binomial number
and what is the probability to infect a
given other individual
well it is one minus the probability not
to infect the other individual
and that thing was
beat
over n times
this
which was the the length of the
infectious period
and this is of course
approximated by a poisson distribution
and it will be
beta times yota
this means that unconditionally
you infect
then it's no longer independence so if
you have a long infectious period you're
more likely to infect each of the other
individuals
so the the infection
will
whether you infect two different
individuals they will be dependent if
you have a random infectious period
but anyway it will be mixed
poisson
with beta times this
random variable which is the infectious
period
and for the
two special cases that i talked about
earlier
the read frost model where we assume
that the infectious period was not
random it was equal to one let's say
then
you in fact
then is no longer mixed person it is
times beta
or
in that case beta is equal to r naught
so it will be poisson or not
in the in the markovian case
then if you remember i said
that it was either exponential one or
exponential gamma
then it is possible to show that you
have the mix poisson will then become
geometric
uh
with parameter gamma divided by
gamma plus beta and that in terms of or
not that will be
geometric
one over one plus or not
and if you
if you have a
if you have if you know the offspring
distribution in a branching process you
compute
pi
so that's the probability that the
branching process goes extinct but i
rather prefer to call it that you have a
minor outbreak
if you remember how to do that you sort
of condition on how many were are born
in the first generation
so you condition on let's call this
thing
z this
random variable z
and if you
if k individuals are born in the first
generation then of course all of these k
wrong
offspring their resulting
branching process all must go extinct so
the probability for that is
pi raised to the power k
and this is
then the same thing as the expected
value of pi raised to the power z
so this is the probability generating
function
so
it means that pi solves
i equals j of pi
so that is how you derive
the probability of a minor outbreak
[Music]
how about the final fraction infected
and let me stress that
we're conditioning on
in case of a major outbreak
then
you should think like this
pick
a random individual
then uh
what let's call that individual eye
consider
our
susceptibility set
so what is that
well here is
my individual eye
and the first generation of this
susceptibility set
are those
so maybe i am i my susceptibility
first generation of my susceptibility
set
are those individuals that would infect
me directly
if they get infected
so you draw the areas going in to you
rather than going out to you
and then the next generation are those
individuals
who would infect the first generation
in my susceptibility set so maybe there
are two people that would infect this
guy
and no one would infect that guy and
maybe one person would infect this guy
so that is the second generation
so the generation one
those
who
would impact me
generation two
those
who
would infect
generation two
generation one
and so on
the big
difference now
is that
consider
me
what is my
if you call it the the in what is my
in-going degree distribution
well
this arrow here
is completely independent of this arrow
here which in turn is independent of
this arrow here because these
are potential transmissions but from
different individuals
contrary to
when you consider the index case and
look at who would he or she infect
because here there is dependence if my
random infectious peers is round sorry
if my infectious spirit is random then
these three arrows
whether they are there or not are not
independent events
but here they are
which means that
my
susceptibility set
is approximate i'm doing this a little
bit sloppy it's approximately branching
process
but it's very connected to the
the eredus
really
network because of these independence
so maybe i should stress
due
to
independence
in
in
degree
and then
i'm said
i said we are assuming that there is a
major outbreak suppose
there
is a major outbreak
then
then this individual eye
individual i
will
get
infected
if and only if
our
susceptibility
set is infinite
why is this
uh well i don't know
i think i don't know the details
but i know that it's the pro probability
that there are two infinite components
in random graphs infinite size
components in random graphs
is zero so if
my susceptibility set is infinite
and there is a major outbreak starting
from the index case
then
these two sets must coincide
[Music]
so then
then it means that 1
minus 2
it is the probability
for i
not
to get the infected
why is this well if the fraction
we
if the fraction tor is the fraction
getting infected and you pick a random
individual the probability that the
individual is not infected is one minus
tau since you picked it uniformly in the
whole community
and the probability that our index case
does not get infected that is the
probability
that the
susceptibility set is finite
which is the probability that this
the branching process
of
in degrees
goes
extinct
by the way i forgot to
yeah i forgot to say here that this
since
since there is an arrow from each
individual independently
the number of in-going arrows
is binomial with fixed probabilities
uh you know so
probability
for uh
yeah so this corresponds to uh
the in degree being poisson
or not because
we have this independence so there is no
dependence and then we get my in degrees
pass on
so this is the pro the probability of
the branching process of integrity is
going extinct
and when
when the degree distribution or the
offspring distribution
is
poisson lambda
and let's write what this is so this is
then
as before we sum over k
and it is 1 minus
2
raised to the power k
times
0.1 lambda so then r naught raised to
the power k divided by k factorial
times e to the minus r naught so it
should be r naught here
and this is the same thing if you
rewrite this you get this
equal to e to the minus r naught tor so
you end up with an equation 1 minus 2 is
equal to eta minus r naught tor
so the final size
is the
positive solution
to this equation
so this ends what i plan to do a
handwritten i will show some simulations
illustrating these results now but
before i switch off my hand my ipad does
anyone want to ask any questions about
this
so this this independence of your
uh susceptibility set
this process this looks sort of
heuristically to be should be true very
generally
so do we know that for more complicated
process so there's certain processes for
which you can do the whole thing you did
request where you can prove the
differential equation and everything
so but maybe there are situations where
the process is so complicated you can't
really do the differential equation
but you could still prove that this is
correct so we know something about that
if you have some really complicated
process you can't follow
but holistically it should become easier
at the end
but maybe then we can't really prove it
so that's my question
yeah so um
i wouldn't dare saying when
this type of reasoning applies but in
general
very
frequently you can
model
the beginning of an epidemic by a
suitable branching process exactly what
the suitable branching process is but
then it is sort of a forward branching
process
and you you have to define it sometimes
you have to define a multi-type
branching process and otherwise it's
clumps so maybe in a household epidemic
the unit is not the individual but it it
is the households
you have different types of household
size
but anyway if you want if you study
the beginning then you look at this
forward process
whereas if you're interested in the
final size
you rather look at
this
susceptibility set or some people call
it a backward branching process so it is
how to re so you pick an individual at
random and then the question is
is the the the group that would infect
this individual is that group infinite
then you're likely to get infected
whereas if it is finite you're unlikely
to ge or you with probability zero in
the limit that you will get infected
i don't know if this answers the
question but maybe at least it relates
to your question
that was the heuristic i was saying i
got from you
my question is
i don't know if you do this on
a household model on top of a
configuration model this
deleting of batches when your parents
are infected make it complicated enough
that you can't that you cannot prove the
differential equation anymore but maybe
this would still be true houristically
certainly but
it's a sort of
some way to prove this without just
proving anything and he's you see what
i'm saying there may be situation where
you're just you can't prove everything
but maybe sometimes we can't really
prove everything but we could still
prove this
so have you encountered an example where
you wrote a paper you could prove the
final size but you couldn't prove the
beginning size or you couldn't no that's
a good that's a good question you're
right that
in fact it's easy if this particular
example is the
the final size is easier because you
have this independence whereas in the
the beginning you don't have
independence so it's harder
you're right i don't
i have at least not on top of my mind i
can come up with an example when you can
compute the final size but not the
initial phase that would be very
interesting
uh to to yeah so the answer is i don't
know and
also that it's an interesting question
to see if there are such situations
so when you come maybe we can start a
little research group
yes
so we can discuss this when i
come to berkeley hopefully
uh
okay let me then go over to my slides so
i would actually
log out to this
thing how do i do that
so now i
only i'm on the
laptop
it's too small it grows too big
now i will share screen
and now
so can you
can you see the slides
now thank you
very good
so uh now
as i said i will
not go into any details of proofs but
more a little bit of heuristic and more
of an overview
and i must admit that okay what i said
that last time it was none of my own
results but today i'm sort of focusing
on things where i have been working not
all results
are
are my own
but there is more about
who has done what in the actual papers
so first some simulations from the
standard as i are illustrating the
results i proved earlier then i will
talk about my most recent result which i
find rather interesting and it's called
optimal prevention
so it has nothing to do with networks
and in fact it's the deterministic model
but then i will go to epidemics with
networks and i will start off by having
fixed networks
and then i will uh
talk about networks that
vary over time as an effect of the
actual outbreak i will try to motivate
why this can be the case in reality as
well
and then i will come back to this
optimal prevention thing
so please
interrupt me if there are some things
and that is unclear so here's a very
very short
recapture of this markovian in
particular the markovian sir epidemic
model so we use an sior model
recall that we start with one infected
rest being susceptible and we have a
fixed community of size n
[Music]
each infectious individual has
infectious contacts that rate beta and
each time you pick a uniformly chosen
individual
if this individual happens to be
susceptible that person gets infected
and other contacts have no effect
and if it's the markovian version of the
model each infectious
individual recovers at rate gamma
so the model parameters are beta and
gamma and we have the population size
and r naught is
beta over gamma which is the beat that
times the average duration of the
infectious period
i told you
uh
on tuesday
or actually now also
that as
n tends to infinity
the final fraction getting infected
converges to a two point distribution
so there are some minor outbreaks where
a fraction
tending to zero gets infected
or
in the supercritical case the final
fraction getting affected solves
this equation which i just finished on
my
ipad will see an illustration of this
and my other result or one of the other
results
the fraction of positive
vector
then the actual
epidemic plus
converges in probability
to an od system which look looks like
this
this is a
probably the most well known of all
epidemic models so i would call it the
deterministic sir model so the fraction
of susceptible decreases at rate beta
times the rate at which infections in
susceptibles meet
and when this happens they go to being
infectious so there's a plus sign here
but also infectious individuals recover
at great gamma and then they go to the
recovered state
i will come back to this equation in the
prevention thing as well so maybe you
can have this
set a differential equation in mind
so let me first illustrate this thing
that the final fraction getting infected
converges to a two point distribution
zero
and the positive number however the
positive number is only
available
in the supercritical case
so what i've done on the next slide is
that i have simulated this epidemic
in a population
of thousand individuals
and i've simulated 10 000 such
simulations
and the only quantity i ever stored
in each simulation
is how many people got infected so maybe
my first simulation resulted in 601
people getting infected
sorry though yeah man
the third one 39 people got infected so
i store these 10 000 final sizes and i
put the histogram of it and here is how
histogram looks
the first histogram is when r naught is
0.8 i chose his number other arabic
arbitrarily but the important thing is
that it is smaller than one
so then we see that all outbreaks are
small
when i do the same thing with r not
equal to 1.5
we still have some small outbreaks
but now we also have some big outbreaks
and
they are not scattered all over they are
concentrated around 600.
if i would as we see here's the
population size thousand if i would have
done the same thing in a population of
10 000 individuals this mountain would
have been much more peaked
and it seems like the peak is slightly
below 600 individuals
and this agrees very well with this
equation
so if you solve this equation when r
naught is equal to 1.5
then you get that a fraction
at
around 58.3 percent will get infected
so this seems to agree well with the
peak of this
mountain
and of course we have this normal
distribution around it
which i haven't proven but which can be
proven as well
so that was an illustration of the final
size having a two-point distribution
minor outbreaks and major outbreaks and
the major outbreaks are located around
the solution to that equation
and now uh
we go to the
sorry yes
what would it be if you plug in the
array of v85
18
yes that's va5 right
there is a figure of that as well
before i show that figure here is a
simulation of one epidemic but i picked
the typical one
over time so here the x-axis is the the
epidemic process over time and what am i
plotting i'm plotting the fraction of
infectives so what fraction in the
community are currently carrying the
virus
for the standard sior model and i start
with five percent being infectious
and i do this when n is equal to 100
individuals and we see that it's quite
random and here is this flat
so this smooth curve that is the
deterministic sr model
and when i do it with a thousand
individuals we see the fluctuations are
still random but we're approaching the
deterministic one and when you have 10
000 individuals we see that the
stochastic fractions are very close to
the deterministic model
i think here is the graph that you
asked
here is the final size as a function of
r naught
what i illustrated before i said if you
solve
i've sold this numerically on a grid
there so for 1.5 we go up here
and we go horizontally and slow slightly
below 0.6
and when arnold is 3
i should have
drawn a horizontal line here at 1 i
realized but at 3 we are quite close to
100 getting affected i think it's maybe
98
getting affected or
or so of course this assumes that we
have a homogeneous community don't don't
forget that so
if there are some individuals that much
higher less susceptible and some that
are more susceptible there is a small
difference to this
but
still a big fraction will get infected
when you have large arnot
unless there is immunity in the
community of course
and
there are loads of extensions for
epidemic models and there are a lot of
us
well there are a lot of stores problems
for these extensions but there are also
a lot of open problems and what are some
typical extensions
one is that you divide in the
individuals into different types could
be due to age groups due to prior
history of the disease vaccinated and
unvaccinate and whatnot
well here comes including vaccination
you can also include other preventive
measures
of course an important thing is to not
to neglect that we have social
structures in the community and the most
common such models are network epidemics
which i'll talk more about and household
epidemics which i will not talk more
about
then you can introduce a latent period
you can introduce waning of immunities
after some time in the recovered state
you can go back to being susceptible you
can if you look of course this is mainly
important if you look at longer time
durations
you can have dynamic populations where
people die and you are born that's also
maybe more interesting if you look at
long time perspectives
but all
complicated and having people moving
makes a preventive measure maybe that
was all up here and
of course a very important thing is that
the more complicated model you have or
maybe you can say the more realistic
model you have
the more complicated
is it
to infer all the parameters of your
model so there's a trade-off
putting more realism seems good but on
the other hand you have to quantify more
parameters and that's
the more parameters you have the more
risky that is
and then one slide
also not none of my results but just how
do you include vaccination in your model
you do it as follows
suppose that you vaccinate a fraction v
before the disease comes if it happens
during the disease you have to do a bit
more complicated but suppose that you
vaccinate you have a vaccine you know
the seasonal influence is soon coming so
you give vaccines to some fraction v
and let's for simplicity
assume that your vaccine acts perfectly
so the vaccinated people have 100
immunity
then
in this standard sir model
you get a new reproduction number
and this is related to the old one as
follows
i mean it's quite clear that suppose or
not is
five
if you vaccinate 40
of the community you would no longer
infect on average five people
but you would on average in fact three
people because of the five people that
you would have infected on average forty
percent of them
are now immune
so forty percent out of five that's two
people so you would only infect three
people
and if you want your new reproduction
number to be smaller than one meaning
that
after vaccination you are subcritical
this is very easy to solve this equation
that is equivalent
to saying that my vaccinated fraction
must exceed this quantity
i think this equation here is probably
the most important equation of all in
epidemic modeling and it is used
extensively by public health agencies
for let's say childhood diseases
so if they know what ornot is
and you have a good vaccine as for
instance with measles and mumps rubella
and whatnot
then this suggests how many in each aid
group you have to vaccinate
to maintain herd immunity so to avoid
big outbreaks so this quantity here is
called the critical vaccination coverage
and if you vaccinate more you reach
what's called herding unit
i have a question
yes
so
this seems it should just be
super general if you really would
vaccinate
random people okay so i mean maybe
different if you've exercised the super
spreaders more than the others
but if you would just vaccinate random
people can't i just think it as it's the
same as if you would just
reduce your susceptible population by a
certain amount
yes you're you are
like always you're a few a slides ahead
of my presentation
you're correct but i will show an
illustration when
if you vaccinate uniformly even in a
more complicated situation this relation
holds so that you're completely correct
but i so i will comment that on that
later on
and if you don't vaccinate
so if you vaccinate too few so maybe the
critical vaccination coverage well for
measles it is probably
measles has or not equal to uh
typically like something like 15 so then
you would have to vaccinate i think one
over one minus one over 15 i think
that's about 93
so suppose that you only manage to
vaccinate 50
can you can you model what will happen
the answer is yes
uh so you would still be super critical
and you can compute the final size
exactly like we did before
but this will be only among the
unvaccinated of course because the
vaccinated group they are completely
immune and you solve that by
doing exactly as we did before but not
for or not but for rv so you then you
get what fraction among the on backs and
it gets infected
uh
just like before
that was my short sort of introduction
illustration and also including
vaccination
so now i will talk about
epidemics but before sorry networks but
before i do i will i take my lib the
liberty to also to talk about the new
recent result of myself
so it is a deterministic model and i'm a
problem or applied problems myself so
this is a little bit outside my comfort
zone perhaps but
anyway
so we're considering an sior epidemic
but now we include intervention
and suppose that there is no vaccine and
we don't foresee any vaccine to arrive
shortly
within the next year or two
but what we can do is we can
this is a misprint you should say
pharmaceutical intervention or
so
define an arbitrary prevention strategy
p
and it what is p well it is a function
of time
and the interpretation of small p of t
is that we have reduced
the con the overall contact rate by a
fraction p
of t so if p of t one day is 50 it means
that rather than having infectious rate
beta
people have
half a beta infection rate
but this p of t we can
maybe we are the public health agency or
we're gold or something like that so we
can sort of choose this
a lot of different preventive strategies
and the question is what is a good
prevention strategy anyway
the g
and this is a function time so for that
i have this capital p as index here
because it will depend on the whole
prevention strategy
and it is exactly as the deterministic
model except that
this
we
we reduce the contact rate by this
fraction p of t so this is the remaining
amount of contacts
so that's the only thing
and at least
numerically we can solve this
up to infinity and then we will get what
would be called the final size
and let's call that zfp
or something else
then there is a cost to a prevention
strategy of course
maybe we're not willing to
have a complete local arm for half a
year so we we get we assign a cost to it
and here we have assumed that we have a
linear cost maybe that's not realistic
maybe
probably the
true cost whatever that is is
it's more uh
why
to reduce the contact rate is probably
cheapest when we started the
no preventions but when we have sort of
reduced our prevention for quite a bit
the cost is probably higher but let's
forget about that and let's assume that
we have a linear cost function
then the question we have addressed is
the following
suppose that
someone has said we cannot have a cost a
prevention a cost to the prevention
exceeding some number
c
and suppose we want to minimize the
total fraction getting infected or the
final size
then which prevention strategy should we
use
this is not the only optimal criteria
another one is to rather than minimizing
the final size you might want to
minimize the maximal number of
infections if you remember that
would correspond proportionally to
not having at any time point in time the
hospitals overloaded so that's a
different optimization criteria which
other people have studied but we studied
the final size and i guess you can
that would probably correspond to the
the number the total number needing
hospital care
it would be proportional to that
yeah well um
maybe the total number of deaths but
then you can
you can say well
if the hospitals get too many people
there then maybe the quality of the
hospital care is
deter deteriorates and then
maybe more people
will die among those getting infected so
maybe it's better to say the number of
people requiring hospital care
so here
this is the number of effectives in the
uncontrolled model the standard sior
model so it looks it goes up
here the number of this is the peak the
number the incidence peak and then it
goes down
and here are a few different suggestions
for preventive measures
so preventive measure one says that
have a complete lockdown right away and
then
maybe this is one month then after one
month we go back to complete normality
prevention strategy
three says let's wait for two months and
then we have a complete lockdown
prevention strategy this
four says have a fifty percent locked
down for two months uh
in this period of time
prevention strategy five says let's
increase the lockdown
over time sort of
slightly sort of mimicking the
uncontrolled incidents and then have it
drop or 25 percent lockdown for
four months or you can go up and down
whatever so there's a wide range of
possible prevention strategies
and the question is
which of these or any other strategy is
the best one
if we want to minimize the total
fraction getting infected and remember
that all well here is one having a
complete lockdown and then a gradual
decay as well
and at least
as you see this is handwritten but my my
aim
was to have all of these different
prevention having the same integral
which corresponds to having the same
overall cost
was there someone wanting to say
but there are certain things which are
counter-intuitive here right so if i
would just
put
all my resources in the beginning you
might say
i sort of i kill the infection but in
your continuous model there's sort of
some tiny epsilon left yes that's a good
problem that's a good comment so this is
a deterministic
so this is a determinate this is a
deterministic model and it can never go
extinct then you might say well in in
reality we have a stochastic model and a
finite population so then if you put in
massive lockdown in the beginning
maybe you will manage to have this go
the epidemic going extinct and that
would of course be very successful
however then you would require that
there was no no further uh immigration
of infectives so i think that strategy
might work in islands like maybe new
zealand but
if for one country or one state in u.s
or one country in europe i think it's
impossible to believe that there will be
no further influx of infectives
so this would be right
so in your continuous model this would
indicate if i put all my resources in
the beginning
all i'm doing is okay so i will start
with
epsilon people infected and reduce it to
epsilon over 500
and then your infections are just on its
course and you get exactly the same as
before and you wasted all your resources
that's correct
you the the only the only positive thing
you have done then is that you have
delayed the epidemic in some situation
that might be good but the final size
will be unch
be the same so that's completely correct
anyway
think more about this if you get bored
from the other things i will
say i will talk about the optimal
solution at the end of the presentation
uh i think i will skip the uh
now forget about this prevention i will
return to it at the end of the
presentation
very briefly but now let's talk about
networks before i say networks there are
a lot of different heterogeneities you
can think of individual heterogeneities
and you individuals might differ in
terms of susceptibility infectivity or
the overall contact rate
[Music]
and also
yeah how whom they contact and the
overall contact rate so then you say
well if that's true why do i even talk
about the more the standard sior model
well i think that this simplification
that i talked about
still makes sense for some diseases it's
a fairly good approximation for some
diseases
in particular for diseases that
that have high infectivity
so
the more infectious disease this i think
the less problematic it is to make these
simplifications whereas for diseases
that are less infectious then you need
it's more important to take the
different heterogeneities into account
and the least infectious
type of this infectious disease you have
is sexually transmitted diseases but
also some others so then
heterogeneities really matter
if you're interested in individual
heterogeneities you do what's called a
multi-type epidemic which is related to
a multi-type branching process i will
skip that
and if you have households then as i
said earlier
the the trick then is not to consider
individuals as your unit but to consider
the household as your unit then then
you have different types of individual
different household sizes but also
households of the same size they have a
random
infectivity because in some household
size
four everyone gets infected so they are
more doing more infections outside
whereas an other household
with four people
perhaps only one person gets infected so
they will infect fewer outside their
households so also the infectivity is
more random in that situation
but now let's go to epidemics
for the rest of this presentation except
the final slide will be a solution to
this
prevent optimal prevention
everyone knows what the network is here
it is used for describing the social
structure in the community
so for that reason it makes sense to
consider networks that are undirected
because usually if
i'm a friend of you
you are a friend of me so most of these
networks are undirected
so what is a good random network well of
course that depends on what particular
disease you're interested in and in
particular how it spreads
but also
in some situation you might know a bit
about the networks and in other
situations you might not
things you might know about is the
degree distribution
how many friends
people have on average on average or in
distribution
[Music]
and then there is another thing called
clustering coefficient was because in
most social networks
if you pick two individuals at random
it's very unlikely that they are
connected to each other
but if you pick two friends of an
individual the probability that these
two friends also know each other is much
higher than two random individuals so
that is captured in
this clustering coefficient and then
there's degree correlation so
individuals with high degree do they
tend to mix with other individuals of
high degree
if if yes you have a positive degree
correlation
if
individuals with high degree rather
tend to
socialize with individuals with low
degree then you have negative degree
correlation
so i think there are features of both of
these
situations but probably
it is
more
positive degree collation in human in
social networks i think
but most of the things in you
but you don't know for instance in
sexual networks fortunately no one knows
how the sexual network in the community
looks like
so then you might use a random model but
you wanted to
satisfy
whatever you know about the network but
other than to treat it as random
i will mainly talk about
the situation when you so i will not
talk more today
when there is positive clustering nor
any specific degree correlations i will
focus on configuration model type
networks
and then now for the moment i will talk
about the simplest as a
epidemic model taking place on such a
social network and that is where you
infect each of your friend independently
with probability p
so that sort of resembles the reinforced
model so you if you want you can think
of that you have
a constant infectious period during
which you infect each frame
independently
but anyway
you have a social network which is
random and on that network if i get
infected i infect each of my susceptible
friends with probability p and then i
recover
the way to model that on the graph is
that you thin
each edge
you remove it with probability one minus
p
then the remaining edges
you can think of them as potential
spreading so if this is your social
network you remove each of these edges
with probability one minus p
maybe i removed these
four edges and i kept these three
so then this is the
this is the thin network and then you
pick a random individual who is your
index case so if it is this individual
the result is that not only this person
get infected but also that one and that
one
whereas these
other people don't get infected so
that's how you would model it
stochastically
but for now let's
focus on
the configuration a network epidemic
for having an arbitrary degree
distribution which i called
this is the degree distribution
and we model
the network by configuration model my
guess is that most people know the
configuration model so i will not
describe it here
and as i said the epidemic model says
that you infect each susceptible friend
with probability p and you do this
independently and let's suppose we have
one randomly selected in the
case
then
what is for this model what is the basic
reproduction number
i
this slide i've i think i've presented
this particular slide over hund in
over 100 presentations
but it's harder when i don't see the
audience in front of me so i will but
when i have do it in live i will always
get people to guess what i've written
down here
so if on average suppose you have a
poisson distribution or some other
distribution and suppose the mean is
five
and suppose you infect each one with
probability p
let's say that p is 0.5
what is the what how many on average you
infect well the first guess that comes
to mind is
of course this
on average and you affect each one with
probability 0.5 you guess 2.5
so that's the first guess that comes
into mind
unfortunately that
is wrong
so why is this wrong
well
if i get suppose i have degree five
if i get infected it means that i have
been infected by one of my friends
so then i only have four friends left
so then the mean reproduction number
should be p times the expected degree
subtracted by
one however that is also wrong
so why is this wrong
this can be explained
by the following picture
here are sort of six
typical individuals this guy has two
friends one friend five friends zero
friends
so who would you bet on
being and
getting infected in the beginning of an
outbreak
i think everyone would bet on this guy
no one would bet on this guy because if
you have no friends you will not get
infected
so
even so if this
here sort of
mimics the average degree distribution
in the community
it does not mimic the degree
distribution among those getting
infected in the beginning
they will have a different degree
distribution
they will have degree distribution which
is the size bias the degree of
distribution so it is
k times
pk
proportional to that
and the reproduction number is
this
mean degree
of the size bias degree degree
distribution subtracted by one since you
were infected by one person
and multiplied by the probability that
you infect each of them
in terms of the original distribu degree
distribution this look has a following
expression where v of d is a variance of
the degree distribution
so
in the the basic reproduction number
does not only depend on the transmission
probability and the mean degree but it
also depends on the tail of the degree
distribution
and that is unfortunately
that is unfortunate because nearly all
empirical networks that have been
analyzed tend to have a heavy tail
degree distribution
which means that this factor here is
substantial
so even when the transmission
probability is small
and the mean degree is small you can
still be super critical from the fact
that
the variance of the degree distribution
is large
[Music]
yes and you can
compute these things
the probability of a major outbreak
and uh also the size
i'm not going to details but you can do
that so in a similar way
to
what i described earlier but slightly
more complicated not that much more
complicated
so now we go to vaccination and now i
will illustrate what
christian
[Music]
mentioned earlier i think
so how about if we vaccinate in this
model
well then the question is who do we
vaccinate
let's start with the simplest case if we
vaccinate the randomly chosen
individuals then
the new reproduction number
is
as christian already realized
it is the original one
multiplied by 1 minus the fraction
being vaccinated
so this means that you need to vaccinate
the same type of expression of course or
notice
before but still if you know what
you have to vaccinate and if you
vaccinate such that the new reproduction
number is more than one then you avoid
future outbreaks the critical
vaccination countries as before
however this is problematic because if
we have a very large or not it means we
have to vaccinate the huge fraction in
the community and maybe this is not
possible
i mean if the variance is large it would
mean that if we vaccinate uniformly we
have to vaccinate close to everyone
maybe that's not possible for some
vaccines maybe the vaccine doesn't work
perfectly and then
even if you vaccinate 100 you might not
do it well enough
so can we do better than selecting
vaccines at random
uh then if you think a little bit about
it i think
that was also mentioned
lost
or recently
you should of course vaccinate social
people the super spreaders
the problem is of course that
most of the time you don't know
who are the
the
you don't know the social network there
is no list of who has most sexual
contacts or who has most social contacts
but maybe you can get tried to get that
somehow but if not here is an academic
example of
a better vaccination strategies and it
goes as follows it's called acquaintance
vaccination
so you pick individuals at random
but rather than vaccinating them
you vaccinate one of these randomly
selected individuals friends so the
friends of the randomly selected
individuals
by doing doing this
you will vaccinate individuals having
this size bias degree distribution
rather than original one
and this is much more efficient
of course it wouldn't be realistic but
one thing you could do if it is
sexually transmitted diseases you might
maybe you say
here is your vaccine but i we would also
like to vaccinate your partner so then
you would vaccinate
some randomly chosen individuals but
also their partners and typically
partners are more sexually active it
follows from the sad fact that your
friends
have more friends than you do
so that would be more much more
efficient which is illustrated in this
figure
here we have the critical vaccination
coverage for some situation when the
degree distribution is poisson
here's a acquaintance vaccination and
here's a uniform vaccination so not a
huge difference
but then when we picked a heavy tail
degree distribution i forgot exactly
which one it was because this is
14 year old i think
then
the acquaintance vaccination it suffice
to vaccinate 50
whereas we would have done uniform
vaccination i think we would have needed
to vaccinate close to 77
so that illustrates that acquaintance
vaccination would be much better
so that was
what i planned to say about
epidemics
on a fixed networks and then i will move
on to the
more complicated situation of what i
call adaptive networks but before i do
that is there any question on these
fixed networks
yes
so if instead of vaccinating i would
just say
okay let the people get sick and wait
for hurt immunity
and now since
the infection tends to do exactly what
you're trying with your sexual contact
it will infect my friends
so
the natural immunity the natural health
immunity should therefore work sort of
better on power law
graphs and or non-parallel graphs is
that
is that true
yeah um
i missed a little bit what you said but
i think i still got what you aim for so
if if you have a heavy tail degree
distribution the effect of that let's
say if you fix the mean of a degree
distribution and then you play around
with the variance then the bigger
variance
the bigger or not will be
that is always true however it is not
true that the
final fraction getting infected
increases with a variance typically
it's the opposite
that
well that depends on
the trans the overall transmission rate
let's let's say but
if
if you have a very
heavy tail degree distribution
then you can have a situation where you
have a very large r naught but if you
just let the epidemic run a rather small
fraction get infected and
it's the super spreaders that get
infected and not so many more let's say
i don't know if that is what
so it is not
or not is monotone in the variance if
you fix the mean but the final size is
not monotone in the very if you fix the
mean
that connects to your question
i didn't hear
so i assume i will continue
this was not quite my question but i
think it's related to it i was asking
about hurt immunity
which seems to be similar because again
if you have large variants
then you might naturally infect the
super spreaders first and once you have
infected the super spreaders you might
already have had a munich tbs in a
homogeneous one you don't have it yet
yes that is true in fact
that is i will not i don't have that in
my slides here but uh
well the at least the paper that has
been cited the most by far of all
wallpapers i've written was the paper i
wrote
science
uh june 2020 so right after the during
the early stage of the pandemic and
there we showed that
if we acknowledge
that
if we acknowledge that
a community is heterogeneous
then the herd immunity level is actually
smaller than if
we
treat it as a uni sort of homogeneous
community
i think that
i i cannot
talk everything today maybe we can
discuss this more um so i will continue
now
that paper that i talked about was
published in science i guess that's also
partly why it was
cited quite frequently
so now let me talk about
networks which change over time
so
if you have no preventive measures
depending on what model you have you can
hopefully you can try to compute what
fraction will get infected as a function
of all your modal parameters so theta is
the vector of your parameters
however
at least if you have severe diseases
then even
if the society does not invoke any
preventive measures individuals will
take
precautions anyway they might isolate
themselves they might distance
themselves from infected people they
might wash their hands more or if it's a
sexually transmitted disease they might
start using condom or
whatever and this
um
i it was the work here was initiated
before uh
kobe 19 so we were mainly inspired by
iabola where it was clear that
people changed behavior because they got
frightened of the ebola outbreak
and this was manifested in the sense
that there were no at least in the
beginning there were no sort of
public health measures but still the
final size was much smaller than
anticipated by the the model
so
adaptive dynamics is models where
individuals change behavior
as an effect of the epidemic process
and i will focus on the situation
where we have a network
so you have some friends
and but if
some of your friends get infected
then
you might stop seeing them
so
what is the effect of social distancing
from
neighbors or friends neighboring is in
the graph sense but maybe in a social
sense it would mean friends
so this we have done in a series of
papers
uh
and this these happen in continuous time
and as before we're considering a large
population
and i would assume that the social
network
is described by the configuration model
and
before the epidemic
this network is static
and on that we have a transmission model
you infect a trade lambda and you
recovered rate gamma i'm sorry that this
is no longer beta it used to be beta in
the homogeneous case but here for some
reason we have called it lambda
so
then the social distancing works as
follows
so if you are susceptible
and you have some infectious neighbors
then you
rewire your edge to that individual
at a rate
which is
called omega times alpha
and you drop your air
individual
at rate omega
times one minus alpha so omega is the
rate at which you do something and alpha
is the probability that's that something
is that you connect to a new individual
randomly chosen
and one minus alpha is the probability
that you simply drop this edge
tom can you be clear because i
i thought you would do something and
this looks different so if i have 50
friends
yes and i'm susceptible and one is
infected then everywhere all my 50
friends are only no
you only rewire
from those that are infectious
so you can sort of
maybe a better thing is to think of
omega is the rate at which you discover
that your friend is infectious
and then you take one of two actions one
is to drop that connection and the other
action is to
rewire to a new friend who hopefully is
susceptible so you only do this to
infectious individuals
so the model parameters are lambda
that's a transmission rate to each
friend
so it's in this is the individual
transmission rate so if you have five
friends you infect each of them at rate
lambda gamma is the recovery rate omega
is the rate at which you you let's say
you discover that your friend is
infectious and you take some action
and alpha is the probability that your
action is to rewire to a new friend
alpha you drop
and d is your degree distribution which
has mean mu
so no latent period no and we have
constant infectivity more consumption
the special case where there is no
rewiring well then the model is no
rewiring so that is well understood that
it has been analyzed by many models
that's just what i talked about earlier
the network model without any action
but when omega is positive
we can consider the situation that alpha
is equal to zero
and
alpha is positive alpha equal to zero
means that you only drop
you only drop edges and that turns out
to be
at least not as hard to the situation
when you also rewire
and we have had quite uh
complicating factor is that the
probability to get infected from a
neighbor changes over the course of the
epidemic
an obvious result is suppose that each
individual has their own omega
so i
this model everyone has the same omega
but suppose each individual has their
own omega
so
omega is the rate at which i take an
action when
or
yeah take an action when a friend of
mine is infectious
then it is clear that the quicker i do
this
the
the
the more likely is it that i escape
being infected so the probability to get
infected decreases
with this rate omega
that is clear however so i'm mixing
slightly here
but up in the model everyone has the
same omega but
still sort of from an individual
perspective it makes sense
to have a big warming up
and this is how it looks so
if this is an infectious individual and
this is me i'm susceptible then i have i
have i seem to have three friends one is
susceptible i do nothing here's an
infectious
person so i take action at relate oh my
god to that guy i take action to that
guy at later on again and the action
could be that i either drop this edge
or else that i
rewire it and then i would pick a random
individual in the community
so that's the model
i realized that
so can someone tell me how much more
time do i have i don't have a
full working cloak i think i don't have
that much more time how much more time
it's official four minutes but maybe a
little bit more
four minutes
but you're getting a little more that's
it you can get a little bit more
okay
but i will i think i'm approaching down
there but anyway
uh
the beginning of this
outbreak
uh
is possible to analyze
and then in fact it doesn't matter if
you drop or rewire because
even if you rewire it's very unlikely
that you will rewire to someone who's
not susceptible so dropping and rewiring
will be the same thing
and the basic reproduction number is
similar to before so it is the expected
value this size biased degree
distribution times the probability that
you infect the neighbor and that is now
this is the rate at which to infect this
is the rate at which your friend that
you recover and this is the rate at
which your friend
drop
drops or rewires away from you
so if you look at this expression
clearly arnold increases with the
infection rate and decreases with the
rate of recovery and decreases
with
the rate of
taking action or wiring and dropping and
this is exactly what you would expect
and we also see that if omega is big
enough whatever this is if omega is big
enough this quantity is below one so
if you rewire or drop quick enough you
will be sub-critical
the dropping model
is easier to analyze
and they are
sort of a big
nice observation is that
rather than uh
thinking of
me rewiring away from someone you can
think of it that it is that person who
informs you that they are infectious
and these individuals inform their
friends independently at rate omega
that's an identical model but then you
can modify this model by saying that
an infectious vin individual does not
inform their friends independently but
instead they inform each of their
friends at the same time but with the
same rate then you get a slightly
different model but it turns out that
it's not such a big difference
and this model is much easier to analyze
because in fact
this modified model is identical to a
model without rewiring
but having
a bigger
rate of recovery
probably this was a bit complicated but
anyway so this can be solved quite
easily the more complicated situation is
when you also rewire so what i said
before
the result follows there are two
interesting quantities i think one is
what is the
the final size
as a function of the rewiring rate
so you would expect that the more you
rewire the fewer people will get
infected but this
theorem
proves that is not always the case
so there are
degree distributions and parameter sets
such that
you will have
a bigger outbreak when you rewire as
compared to when you don't do anything
so you will have a bigger outbreak when
people take preventive measures
the heuristic explanation is that
considering
an individual with very high degree even
if it rewires it will most likely even
if it rewires with a small rate it will
most likely get infected
and if it does it might have rewired
to
individuals with a lower degree
and
yeah i'll skip that so now let's
consider the final size as a function of
the infection rate
then
let's we looked only at the city we had
a lot of problems proving anything so we
looked at only error there's really
networks
with mean mu
so if we fix the mean of the the error
network assuming it's bigger than one we
fix the recovery rate
we fix the rewiring rate and we fix the
rewiring probability
then we said
the critical lambda looks as follows
this is exactly the lambda value
it's the critical lambda value such that
the basic reproduction number equals
zero and when sorry equals one and when
the basic reproduction equals one
there will be no big outbreak
but then we have a theorem that if
two criteria are fulfilled
then
the final size if you are just above
this critical value
will not be zero but it will be strictly
away from zero
i will now
end by illustrating these first these
two results so here is the final size as
a function of the rewiring probability
for some specific choice of degree
distribution we see when we don't rewire
i think the population size was five
thousand when we don't rewire we on
average got 3 200 people getting
affected but then with rewiring you see
that there are even more people getting
injected
this turned out to be also case for some
empirical networks that we looked at we
downloaded 12 networks and a few of them
actually had this feature that
if we played around the rewired we would
get a bigger outbreak
the last illustration which we proved
most recently is the final size as a
function of
the transmission rate
for some specific choices in a
population 1000
here
if you remember there was a criteria
here
this criteria
is fulfilled in the right figure but
this criteria is not fulfilled in the
left figure
so in the right figure we see that when
lambda is small
we only have small outbreaks but when
lambda is
above this critical value we
suddenly have some big outputs but
they're not
there are no outputs here well there
were two of them
when in the
situation there was no discontinuity we
see that we they follow this line
okay
so that was
this result about a dynamic networks two
rather surprising results that the
final size is discontinuous in the
infection rate
and that
if rewire
you might even
do worse than not rewiring
finally
the result about the optimizing
preventions which
preventive strategy is the best
given my criteria the answer is
that we should do nothing until the peak
of the incidence and then we should have
a complete lockdown for as long as we
can afford and then we go back to
normality
this a little bit so we also said
suppose we cannot have a complete
lockdown suppose that we can have uh
let's say a 50
lockdown at the most or 75 lockdown at
the most and the next slide i think is
for the situation when we at most could
have a 75 percent lockdown
sorry here is the result
given the starting value and suppose
that we want to
minimize the total incidence i didn't
introduce but this is a final fraction
getting infected
among all piecewise continuous
intervention strategies
with the overall cost not exceeding this
constant c1 and with
the maximum the lockdown does not exceed
some other constant which in this
numerical slide we chose to be 75
then the best intervention strategy says
do nothing
and then do the maximal uh
possible lockdown and then go back to
doing nothing
and here is a figure
so what is this
this is i of t the black curve is
without interventions
and then the blue curve is the optimal
strategy if you want to minimize the
total fraction getting infected so then
we should
because 75 we should start slightly
before the peak of the uncontrolled
incidence we go up to 75
until our money
until the cost has exceeded and then we
go down to zero so we see the
the incidence will of course before
con intervention it will behave just
like no intervention and then when we
have 75 percent lockdown it will
suddenly drop
and go down like this
so that is the best strategy
the red strategy is the best strategy if
we want to minimize the maximum size
any time point in time
so this would be a strategy for
making it pleasant or as least
unpleasant as possible for the hospitals
so we would have sort of
keep the
incidence at the maximum level
and the best strategy for that has been
proven by others
and it says you should start lockdown
slightly earlier then gradually drop it
i think
even if people are
okay with wanting to minimize the
optimal
the total number getting infected i
think very few people from public health
agencies would be comfortable saying do
nothing up until we more or less have
the peak incidence
so
let's say
as a toy example suppose you present
that this this blue here is the best
thing
we can do
i think they would say no i don't trust
you i give you some more money
so you can start your prevention early
so
end it here but start it earlier
maybe sometime a week earlier or
something like that what would then
happen
so here is the original one the best and
here is where they give you one more
week
of lockdown and do it before
the effect is that you will follow the
red curve but then when you stop you
will have a new big outbreak
and we see that the over this is the
overall fraction getting infected so the
consequence of adding a week of
prevention
before
the optimal solution
is that you will get the big second wave
and if you look at the total fraction
getting infected you will hardly gain
anything from having no
prevention so rather counterintuitive by
adding prevention early
worse
it's not contract
[Music]
sorry
i find it very intuitive because if you
prevent too early
then you will freeze the epidemic when
when you are affected but still high
and you just wait time you can do as
long as you want to sort of if you could
do it perfectly
and then eventually you just start at
the same place where am i affected is
still high if you start yes big or later
our effective is smaller than one and
now it's used
so yes
you're completely correct so it is not
counterintuitive still
i think most people would find it
counterintuitive
but so i think you're an exception and
um
i've given this presentation
i've given these slides
presented these last slides a few times
and nearly always people
are very surprised about this
anyway i'm done if there are no
regarding
this or anything else
okay thank you so much tom so let's find
the speaker
[Applause]
so maybe some quick questions
ask some questions i guess
thanks for that talk is it possible to
reason about are not if um you're not
choosing the first individual randomly
but
maybe like a influence maximization case
where you
choose the first person to maximize the
spread
so
or
who is the index case
has a big effect
at least if you consider network modules
or whatever who is the index case has a
big effect on the probability of an
outbreak
however who is the index case
has very little or i would even say no
effect
on
the basic reproduction number
so it does affect the probability of
seeing an outbreak
but it does not affect sort of the
asymptotic
if
it does not affect if it takes off
it doesn't matter who was in the case
so
who is the index case will that has a
big impact on if it takes off but if it
takes off it no longer matters who was
the index case if i put it like that
thank you
anyone else
maybe i can ask a quick question so what
about this degree degree the uh
distribute correlations so i think that
if you have haps connected to caps then
probably they they form some kind of
backbone early on so can you comment
briefly maybe on
what would happen if you have um
[Music]
positive correlation or negative
correlation how would it affect the
process
so i think
this will depend on so the overall
amount of trans uh one on the overall
infection rate let's put it so
let's see now
if you have a highly infectious disease
then
the only ones that will escape are
individuals with low degree that connect
to other individuals with a low degree
so if you have a sort of if you have a
high infection rate
my guess is that the final size will be
smaller if your degree correlation is
positive
where as
well i'm not 100 sure whereas if
if you the the overall transmission is
not so
high
then the only way to infect the
people with low degree is if they tend
to connect to other individuals of high
degrees so that's star formation if you
have a star formation then also
individuals
are likely to get infected uh
i don't know that's well enough but i
think some stuff is known about the
degree correlation of course it depends
on how you define it
there are many different models
producing positive and negative degree
correlation but
i think i didn't respond well enough but
some stuff is known about it
and it depends on sort of the overall
transmission rate
i said rigorously no no is that more
simulations and physics kind of arguing
well i have analyzed the model having
i am frank ball we sort of defined a
model inspired by the configuration
model where we also had clustering a
parameter affecting the clustering and
another parameter
affecting the degree correlation so for
that particular model we were able to
show
that
how the degree correlation was of
affected the final size
but i don't remember all the details
of that
now maybe you could add that reference
to your slides before we post them
yes
okay so thank you so much so i guess
that we can keep it as open problem
maybe
the future so thank you so much again
it's time to come
for one more time and talk
thank you very much
i guess you've got no break
eleven
thank you